sur le conseil municipal qui s'est qui
s'est tenu il y a il y a deux jours de
cela il se trouve que j'avais
je trouve que ce jour là j'étais à
Saint-Brevin et que j'ai je me suis
rendu en mairie pour saluer
madame Paco la mère et
en lui réaffirmant qu'on serait là pour
elle quand on serait là pour elle et
notamment qu'on allait sécuriser
le conseil municipal qui s'est tenu en
soirée et auquel effectivement était
présent des des opposants
à ce fin des opposants appartenant à ce
collectif
Brévinois de enfin anti-cada voilà vous
donnez le volume de 11 pour la
gendarmerie et le renseignement
territorial ou non vous donnez le
chiffre de 20 et pour la gendarmerie et
le renseignement territorial de mémoire
ils étaient 11 voilà ils ont assisté
calmement au conseil municipal d'après
mes informations ils n'ont rien dit il
faut dire que autour il y avait quand
même pas mal de pas mal de gendarmes ça
aurait été osé
osé oser de de vraiment oser de
perturber la séance alors effectivement
à l'issue du conseil municipal il y a eu
des échanges vifs avec l'équipe
municipale nous étions présents
et nous avons raccompagné la mère à son
domicile pour qu'elle se sente
complètement en sécurité et Madame Paco
a remercier à remercier les gendarmes
je note aussi que
à l'occasion
de son élection dans le fauteuil de mer
de mémoire c'était le 9 le 9 juin nous
étions présents et nous avions
refoulé un des individus quelques
individus ultra-droits qui qui était qui
s'était rendu à Saint-Brevin
manifestement pour perturber la tenue du
conseil
nous les avons donc repoussé pour que le
conseil et l'élection de la mer se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
sans qu'on puisse retenir une quelconque
qualification pénale à cette présence